yeah this is uh not good here on this
friday morning not the way we want to
start the day it was a calm morning
until about half an hour ago
straight to the spaghetti boy you can
see how red and orange this map is here
this crash is at the 15 northbound in
washington let's take a live look here
looking uh south from this camera you
can see the crash there is a big rig
involved here they have this down to one
lane the paramedics were on scene they
did leave a short time ago see this is
down to one lane it appears a few people
involved in another crash here but
that's two of three another look here
there's also another crash in the same
area some more people got involved here
so the northbound lanes there traffic is
starting to build up it's also building
up south towards downtown because of
this crash a lot of people just slowing
down taking a look at this as well so
that's any part of your commute around
the spaghetti bowl there could be some
major device i'll send it back to you